hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay I'm over my
little episode there I'm okay now I'm
all good
can't you tell anyway one of you
mentioned I passed by a power node ah ah
thank you for that I must have missed it
in my rage but I'm all good now I'm
already past this part so no monsters
left except for this one that pops out
of here when I go up here oh hello
also scary
my buddy my buddy okay I'm starting to
realize that the line gun is like
unbelievably powerful sometimes I'm an
upgrade it instead of whatever the hell
I upgraded before - I've already a
there's like upgrade central I like that
I'll head up that way hot-diggity yeah
more width I can cleave like every enemy
in the area I do need to hit those
damages though but I'm in a good
position to hit them later
um I don't know the all fired
oh yeah they're all fire sends a charge
that explodes after a while but it's
it's hard to time so it's not my
favorite thing in the world that's close
to the detonator which is awesome I
don't know why I didn't try the line gun
in the last game line gun but I guess I
was just stupid one and either
I saw you shut up douchenozzle
ah don't like those things just gotta be
careful on another power node hell yes
ah how did I get the plasma cutter out
when did that happen
really I got all this line shot of our
notes I can I'm wasted yeah yeah let's
put it up in order
oh sure in the timer oh that would be
useful
mm-hmm
okay but anyway I need to go for this
damage not that it did like one-shots
things anyway if I hit him up in the
arms or down legs up in the arms I think
one shot because I don't think the
enemies can actually do anything if they
don't have any arms therefore they're
automatically
they can't attack you then the point was
it
oh that's please yeah with the C cheese
for here oh whatever
just whatever up this looks
what it what what
it vanished it freakin vanish yeah I
think this ever it is all right there
dajin
it's haunted I got again right away
look out there I go out that's so weird
what purging life somewhere Wow
something
wha-wha
hi oh wow I saw that what what ha got ya
where the hell were you not your claws
ok guess I guess I should get life
support back up
hey no thing up there it is autumn so
great oh there it is I'm the bit oh
there it is light yep you lady you're
trying to kill me cut your head off
right there
it us don't look at me like that you
should dammit
Oh too bad
what's my objective tell me lay it on me
tie dementia blah blah we can ID
elevator done that as disabled security
mainframe haha
if they think they can lock me in here
they're sorely mistaken the program is
probably controlled by the array
security mainframe I need to find a way
to disable it wow that's nice and big
oh here oh oh don't like tunnels okay so
I got to get in like there there doesn't
matter
reroute
we're out
the tunnels
this is what I'm afraid it's gonna be is
gonna be left out a dead space 3 you
know cramped dark I mean the scariest
games make you scare yourself you know
ah what the hell no uh-uh
shut up lady about you
oh okay the symbols you're supposed to
put them which ways up
okay
two girls up
I just saw the rotating arm there dar
infinity shine up in the circle penis
you got it and penis
no okay give us to be the other way
please fiddle around this nope I get out
here
he's stupid I know which waves was but
someone mentioned to me that there was a
nice trick that's probably to do with
he's in
ah oh wait is that just
oh yeah that's okay ah that's green
the Lowe's Easter Egg
I just that's square supposed to go
alright I'll just put I miss out on the
Easter egg and no big deal
can't be Zachary can it ah first wall
your face
um okay I think that's it
Oh what do you know
[ __ ] shut up use my javelin a bit more
oh I can flippy-floppy okay
okay all right
all I get is my javelin and then the
electricity to kill volatile gas I don't
know why I didn't mean that before hmm
little guys find a panel ha oh you're
not look at sapis app get out what the
hell gimme no yeah me
no kidding me gimme that
yeah these panels in a way ok
let me draw a fiddle around a little
more cuz if there is an Easter egg to be
found
Lou wait no it's blue is this no
they found it only automated mainframe
oh I may have found to pay on Lu
is that perfect blue it looks blue
ah yeah
yeah I'm so smart I got it I think I got
it all unless it's just gonna lead me
into my doom
I did it I did it
oh oh it's a goodie room no power note
thank you
huh that's catchy
Hank
what tell that there's always pang Bell
does that mean I don't know that like
some novelty you're supposed to carry
with you to be envious you a power node
in a box we have to paranhos we yes
awesome
I got awesome mega ultra super awesome
cool
okay all right now I just fiddle with
the thing in the correct order and I'll
be on my merry way don't go flying off
into the sunset
No get out of there no that's wrong no
so many I don't even want to see the
thing about oh yeah there you stupid
panel okay
that did it
okay what what the hell oh oh
okay
oh no oh no it's gonna make me jump out
and blind no I need got the detonator
line good
huh
ah ah
a woman OB @ aw what the hell
yeah dad
oh yeah go skittering off into them of
this YouTube why not
womp oh they're fragile oh come on Oh
laughs fine up even
there we go all methodical God lady
Allah
what the hell when did I put a grenade
over oh when I missed hi of course I'll
write awesome I'll make it progress
that's all the time I got for this
episode thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye bye